pop smoke a rapper on the rise has died
at the age of 20 I rap for the LAPD
confirmed to et that police responded to
an emergency call at 4:20 9 a.m.
Wednesday morning after an unknown
number of suspects in Mass entered a
residence and shot a victim the victim
was then transported to a local hospital
and pronounced dead upon arrival the
incident took place at a rental home
property owned by the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills star Teddy Mellencamp who
addressed the news on Instagram writing
we would like to extend our prayers and
condolences to the family and loved ones
affected by this tragic loss of life
now the hip-hop community is paying
tribute to the young rapper Nicki Minaj
who released a remix of welcome to the
party with pop smoke in 2019 when a
party blog posted on Instagram saying
the Bible tells us that jealousy is as
cruel as the grave unbelievable rest in
peace pop wave oh collaborated with pop
smoke on his song shake the room he
honored him by writing got to know this
kid young boss and the honcho was here
to share that any time you called me
r.i.p chance the rapper also paid his
respects and tweeted you were too young
god bless and comfort your family pop
smokes rap career was on the rise he
just released his highly anticipated
mixtape meet the whoo to the Duke of
Industry and he was also scheduled to go
on toured this spring